Jack Lang postule en effet pour un
nouveau mandat à la tête de cette
institut qu'il avait lui-même créé et
dont la présidence est plutôt un job
sympa c'est payé 10000 euros par mois
avec de très beaux bureaux un des plus
beaux de Paris face à Notre-Dame avec la
possibilité de voyager souvent autour de
la Méditerranée et la possibilité
d'organiser à Paris de multiples
mondanités ce qui tombe bien puisque
c'est l'activité préférée de Jack Lang
en pleine forme il souhaite donc empiler
pour 3 ans ce qui lui permettrait de
rester actif jusqu'à ses 86 ans est-ce
que tu as déjà voulu travailler avec moi
et si oui pourquoi
c'est bon
on arrête les conneries je vais te dire
franchement
j'aurais pu travailler avec toi à
l'époque où tu étais probablement
moins perverti un peu c'est à dire je
pense
l'humanité mais je vais plus pouvoir
passer les portes mais il y a pas que
vous il y a aussi votre camarade
la pagaille
je
trouve que tu t'es un peu perdu
[Applaudissements]
c'est un gadget de penser pour les
relations à distance avec cette bouche
en silicone relie un smartphone vous
pouvez désormais envoyer un bisou à
votre partenaire le dispositif est
équipé de capteurs pour reproduire le
mouvement la pression et même la
température du baiser que l'on adresse
mais sur le web on se demande où est la
langue cet appareil imaginé par un
étudiant chinois vendu 35 euros ne
convainc pas les internautes dégoûtés et
intérêts ils avaient prévu de des
vacances de rêve ensemble au bord de la
mer mais au dernier moment pour des
raisons professionnelles la jeune femme
a été contrainte d'annuler son voyage
Raymond a décidé de partir seul enfin
presque qu'il a imprimé le visage de sa
femme sur un coussin
donc toutes ces activités une façon de
garder celle qu'il aime auprès de lui et
de la faire sourire sans doute de
nombreux gadgets et technologies
incroyables comme un robot anti solitude
capable d'échanger et de construire une
relation un clone éternel doté d'une
intelligence artificielle un
exosquelette connecté pour permettre aux
personnes handicapées de marcher à
nouveau une application qui scanne la
truc de votre chien pour pouvoir
l'identifier évidemment c'est très
compliqué de le surveiller pour de
simples humains et donc tu as ces petits
robots qui ont été programmés pour ça en
fait ils sont équipés de caméras ils
vont surveiller 150 têtes de bétail
chacun est leur caméra leur permettent
et bien de compter les animaux de suivre
leur températures de détecter les
animaux malades et puis ils ont des
petits panneaux solaires pour se
régénérer et s'alimenter en énergie
toute la journée
[Musique]
c'est un tube on peut le dire ça pulse
cette pub qui compte l'épopée donc
d'obalie des verres pâturage de son
village sans ta lire d'Arlan à 1100
mètres d'altitude bon vous êtes ravi de
vos émotions un petit Patrice à peine
mais ça va aller en bon le Tor son
respire on pense à la France et bien
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi comme vous
adoré bravo quel talent magnifique mise
en avant du savoir-faire auvergnat
félicitations a écrit le président de la
République sous la vidéo même commenté
sur Youtube les vidéos incroyable pour
donner rendez-vous pour l'apéro
aujourd'hui au salon de l'agriculture
ça a bien fait rire les clips
regarde il faut y aller
alors moi je fais tout un spectacle à
tristesse
l'allaitement et la mort du cochon donc
quand on commence par la naissance est
fait
ça ça veut dire que du lait après
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
ça te va bien
[Musique]
je suis ravie en plus Aurore va faire
plaisir
le dindon c'est quoi le dindon le
gagnant en quelque chose là non il fait
le pain
après vous avez la chaîne
le cheval
le système politique israélien veut que
des parties totalement minoritaires en
l'occurrence la des parties
minuscules suprémacistes Juifs
clairement raciste mené parfois par des
reprises justice ont un pouvoir
u
on est dans le bazar total
aujourd'hui on est Israël et face à un
dilemme c'est qu'il ne peut alors
apparemment il y a une interruption de
programme donc comment on dit à l'époque
veuillez nous excuser
de programme
indépendant de notre volonté